il est des coins de france où la crise
du coc vite 19 a été moins difficile à
vivre qu'ailleurs
alors
j'ai deux cerises et couverts de somine
pierre sourzat est un retraité qui
habite le lot il est même pas 20 revue
géo et le confinement il n'en a pas
vraiment souffert
pour la profiter du bonheur en plus il a
fait très beau mois d'avril avait fait
sec chaud et du coup
ça s'est très bien passé la campagne on
était vraiment privilégié nous
pierre n'a pas eu peur d'être touchée
par l'épidémie
à 68 ans d'ailleurs il n'a jamais été
vraiment malade durant sa vie sauf une
fois quand il était jeune c'était tilly
à 50 ans une époque où le gel
hydroalcoolique n'avait pas encore
envahi les foyers français
il n'oubliera jamais cette année 1969
une année de première totalement
bouleversé mois de décembre mois j'ai
tombé malade j'ai été un des premiers à
tomber malade je sais que j'ai eu
beaucoup de fièvre voilà et que
rapidement j'ai la bronchite et donc
mes parents se sont inquiétés et le
directeur il a il a téléphoné à mes
parents pour dire il faut rapatrie votre
fils est chez vous parce qu'il sera
certainement mieux chez vous que que
dans le lycée
le diagnostic c'est une grippe mais
anormalement contagieuse et avec des
symptômes citron gingembre
le médecin de saint fabien il avait
parlé d'aller me cérébrale parce que
j'étais paumé j'étais vraiment
mes parents étaient inquiets forcément
est donc j'ai passé pratiquement un mois
confiné la maison 1 cependant il n'y
avait pas que moi de me wade étant donné
qu'il y avait je présume un tiers ou en
quarts des élèves qui étaient encore
celle s au lycée qui n'était pas malade
le directeur après décision de fermer
l'établissement
drôle de coïncidence
annie sa femme se souvient elle aussi
très bien de cette année 1969 elle avait
13 ans vivaient à 100 km de là et elle a
les mêmes souvenirs des symptômes d'une
grippe carabinée
et une école totalement envahie par le
virus on avait de la fièvre on avait des
gros gants millions on était très haut
niveau se sentait pas bien où on était
quand même malade on est revenu en cours
quand même nom à part annoncé tient en
fait pas du tout on n'a pas fait non non
vous posez pas la question on n'était
pas dans une situation
où comment dire à risque apparemment
en fait pierre et annie ont été victimes
d'une des plus grave pandémie du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
la grippe de hong kong qui tua plus d'un
million de personnes dans le monde et
des dizaines de milliers en france
[Musique]
ce qui est très choquant
pour la grippe de hong kong ce sont ces
vingt-cinq mille morts en moins d'un
mois quasi
très rapidement donc il était plutôt
bleu violet il avait beaucoup de gens
qui en bourré
[Musique]
que font les responsables politiques à
l'époque nous avons eu beau fouiller
dans les archives il n'existe aucune
mesure annoncée à même la moindre
déclaration du président pompidou
un constat sidérant
nous sommes en guerre pour nous qui
avons connu des mois de combat national
pourquoi à l'époque at on ignorer ce
virus et pourquoi aujourd'hui
sommes-nous entrés en guerre totale nous
allons vous raconter comment en 50 ans
les français ont à ce point changé leur
rapport à la santé
[Musique]
tout commence en juillet 1968
l'ancienne colonie britannique
hong kong est soudainement frappé d'une
grippe particulièrement environnantes
très vite on isole ce nouveau virus
appelé h3n2 le voici au microscope il
aurait été transmis à l'homme par les
oiseaux
en quelques semaines plus de cinq cent
mille personnes sont malades dans cette
seule région
mais de hong kong cette épidémie n'a que
le nom
[Musique]
si elle porte ce nom c'est parce qu'on
la découvre momo et larry longue mais
elle est née j'allais dire comme eux
neuf fois sur dix dans la chine centrale
à un moment où le ciné totalement fermée
pour cause de révolution culturelle
donc de fait assez qui génère des
déplacements de population important un
peu du lot ce qui favorise en fait la
contagion et la propagation des
épidémies dont la grippe de hong kong
de chine
le virus atteint une partie de l'asie du
sud-est puis l'australie le japon et
l'inde
en septembre c'est le vietnam qui est
touché et très vite le virus traverse
les océans pour atteindre les états unis
et le canada
il faut dire que les américains sont
alors engagés dans la guerre du vietnam
même si il est vrai la voie des armes se
fait toujours en temps
les marines qui en reviennent ramènent
avec eux le virus h3n2 enregistré 25
tuées et 83 blessées dans ces
aux états unis c'est durant l'hiver 68
69 que le virus se propage
ils tuent en moins de trois mois plus de
50000 américains
les salles de classe ce vide et le taux
d'absentéisme atteint des records
[Musique]
premièrement nous savons que le virus de
hong kong est arrivé chez nous
deuxièmement nous savons qu'une large
partie de la population est touchée
[Musique]
un virus qui va profiter du transport
aérien pour se propager à travers le
monde
[Musique]
et la grippe de hong kong a même failli
s'exporter très loin un an avant le
premier pas sur la lune les américains
envoient un équipage en orbite pour
l'approcher et les astronautes souffrent
de symptômes étranges
pour l'instant comme
olivier vous même je pense que j'ai fait
quelques instants avoir une conférence
de presse de houston mais je ne pense
pas qu'il s'agisse de la grippe de hong
kong comme vous disais tout à l'heure je
souhaite qu'ils se disent par exemple
le virus serait dans l'espace mais en
1968 n'a pas encore touché l'europe
à paris la madame grippe de l'institut
pasteur le docteur qu'atteignent est
formel cette épidémie ne nous concerne
pas
en france il n'y a pas d'épidémie
pratiquement en ce moment ni en europe
non plus il ya eu quelques cas qui ont
été
décelés en angleterre et aux pays-bas le
croit enfin il n'y a pas de véritable
épidémie en france
et la france ne se prépare pas du tout à
l'arrivée du virus
[Musique]
pourtant l'année suivante dès l'automne
1969 la grippe de hong kong s'étend sur
le moyen-orient puis s'abat sur l'europe
et l'afrique
[Musique]
bientôt elle devient un mondial
le sud ouest tous le sud ouest est
grippée en france l'épidémie arrive par
l'espagne
dans les landes l'école normale
d'institutrices de mont-de-marsan a
fermé ses portes jusqu'à lundi prochain
le virus remonte par le nord pour
frapper durement la ville de lyon toutes
ces victimes à travers le monde n'y font
rien on croit encore à une simple groupe
due au froid moins sept degrés pendant
la nuit vous sortez le matin atchoum
roulettes grippé rassurez vous vous
n'êtes pas le seul un français sur
quatre à la guerre et on en plaisante
ray presque somme toute après trois
jours de grottes d'aspirine l'édredon
bien chaud cela n'est pas si désagréable
mais en fait la réalité est dramatique
[Musique]
à l'hôpital edouard herriot au sud de
lyon les ambulances affluent et les
morts sont as
[Musique]
à l'époque le professeur de la monica y
était jeune médecin
en première ligne au service de
réanimation
pour lui c'est au mois de décembre 1969
que tout a basculé
dans cette cour n'a vu un afflux de
patients qui arrivait avec
de la toux un essoufflement une détresse
respiratoire enfin comme des poissons
qu'on sort de l'eau
souvent crachant une espèce de mousse
tâter de rose très rapidement le service
de réanimation étaient envahis de ces
personnes là et évidemment il y en a qui
pourrait très vite les services
mortuaires ne n'arrivait pas les évacuer
pour les emmener dans les salles
requises et donc on les mettait au fond
du service dans une petite salle où on
mettait les brancards les uns à côté des
autres
avec ces personnes
un témoignage qui résonnent dans la
france dû qu'ovide 19 en 1969 les
hôpitaux français ont vécu le même
cauchemar qu'en 2020 pourtant aucun
décompte des victimes n'est effectuée
jusqu'à la fin du mois de janvier 1970
mille personnes meurent chaque jour de
la grippe
et ce n'est que bien plus tard que des
épidémiologistes comme antoine flahault
ont chiffré le nombre de morts français
on avait trouvé en 2003
trente et un mille décès dûs en excès
dus à la pandémie de hong kong en france
pendant la deuxième vague de 69 70 et
puis dans une deuxième analyse qui a été
publié je crois en 2007 on a pu rechi
ferez peut-être avec un peu plus de
précisions à 35 mille le nombre de décès
en excès durant cette même période de la
deuxième vague 69 70
trente cinq mille morts comme le
coronavirus la grippe de hong kong a
surtout frappé des personnes de plus de
65 ans
la france à l'époque était alors plus
jeunes
pour joël coste médecin historiens si la
démographie avait été celle
d'aujourd'hui la grippe de hong kong
aurait été une hécatombe
si on applique les taux de mortalité de
la grippe
de l'époque
à une population qui serait celle
d'aujourd'hui on aurait
mathématiquement deux à trois fois plus
de morts que on en a eu à l'époque la
grippe de hong kong avec la structure de
population d'aujourd'hui ça serait entre
70 me laissant mineurs
son décompte quotidien ni même mensuel
des victimes les autorités sanitaires se
limite à quelques déclarations
laconiques
revoici madame grippe en décembre 1969
un mois où le h2n3 a fait vingt mille
morts
une épidémie semble se dessiner dans le
sud ouest il y à quelques cas à paris et
je pense que nous commençons une
épidémie vous êtes quels conseils
pratiques de leurs dix poulains grippe
et qu'il se repose qui prennent des
boissons chaudes
non alcoolisées
le professeur de la monica se souvient
que dans les hôpitaux les victimes sont
à sec et les médecins se sentait bien
seul ce qui était paradoxal aussi à ce
moment là pour nous c'est que quand on
sortait de l'avs dans la rue personne
n'en parlait on voyait pas de masque on
savait juste que les transports en
commun marchait mal que certaines écoles
regroupées des classes parce qu'il y
avait plus de mettre enfin des choses
comme ça mais pas plus
à la télévision on ne parle jamais de
mort
en plein pic de l'épidémie voici comment
est traité le sujet
faire
dans les journaux seule la presse
populaire lui consacre quelques articles
jamais pour interroger le nombre de
morts plus tôt pour évoquer les horaires
des pharmacies de garde ou l'absence des
cheminots
les grands quotidiens d'analystes comme
le monde traite peu le sujet les
articles du monde sont peu nombreux
ouvriers ce ne sont jamais des articles
de première page jamais et qui
dit d'une part cette grippe n'est pas si
différente des précédentes et donc il
faut il faire face comme on ne veut plus
faire face aux précédentes et puis la
grippe va passer
pour les journalistes de l'époque la
grippe n'est tout simplement pas un
sujet
michèle cotta avait une trentaine
d'années en 1969 elle travaillait à
l'express
je l'aimé bien c'est un peu nous pas
croyable aujourd'hui moi je n'ai aucun
souvenir j'étais à l'express à ce moment
là je vois que personne n'en parle à
personne
si on parlait de la grippe voilà mais on
parlait toujours de la grippe mais mais
sans dire que c'est nbi spécifique
spécifiquement dangereuse voilà
il faut dire qu'à l'époque les médias et
les français ont les yeux tournés
ailleurs
nous sommes en ont après mai 68 dès lors
manifestations et violences dont chaque
go et roulé là révolue parce que la
terre
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué cette année
en france qui m'a marqué moi l'élection
du président de la république
[Musique]
les hommes sur la lune spécialement qui
m'a frappé
[Musique]
moi c'est dommage que qu'il n'y ait pas
plus de paix dans le monde parce que les
gens seraient beaucoup plus souple
le pouvoir aussi à la tête ailleurs
le président pompidou vient d'être élu
il a constitué son gouvernement avec à
sa tête jacques chaban delmas
ni l'un ni l'autre ne diront ne feront
quoi que ce soit pour lutter contre ce
virus mortel
robert boulin et le ministre de la santé
la grippe ce n'est pas son sujet il est
tout entier concentré sur sa réforme de
l'assurance maladie qui provoque la
colère des petits commerçants
d'ailleurs quand il accorde un long
entretien à la télévision il n'est
question que de cela et bien le projet
que nous présentons à l'heure actuelle
d'abord un caractère positif par rapport
aux platines négative qui font toujours
formule
la seule trace d'une réaction de robert
boulin date de janvier 1970 deux mois
après le début de l'épidémie
[Musique]
en pleine période de noël la grippe est
la plus impitoyable et le ministre est
interrogé par france soir dans une
courte interview il dit s'être fait
vacciner et encourage les français à le
faire
cette interview at elle un
retentissement particulier
difficile à dire en tout cas à partir de
janvier 1970 les français se précipitent
pour avoir un vaccin sans qu'aucune
politique publique ne les y encourage
moi je me souviens avoir été à lyon en
crue pasteur devant l'institut pasteur
donc à chaque extrémité de la rue il y
avait des
des policiers qui filtrait les gens qui
se mettait en ligne 34 clean et devant
l'institut pasteur on avait sorti des
tables avec le matériel de vaccination
et on vaccinait les gens la chaîne comme
ça
mais les laboratoires pasteur et meirieu
fabricant le vaccin n'ont pas prévu à 6
et très vite c'est la pénurie
et il y a plus surprenant le vaccin
inocule et à la chaîne n'est pas adapté
pour produire le vaccin de la grippe
saisonnière de 1969 les chercheurs n'ont
pas jugé utile de travailler sur la
souche de la grippe de hong kong pariant
sur le fait que l'épidémie allait
disparaître
quand bien même cette souche était
arrivé aux etats-unis au japon ou en
australie bien plutôt chercheurs de ces
laboratoires n'ont pas cru que ce serait
cette souche qui viendraient déferlé sur
le sur le monde va dans l'univers
qu'elle suit et les deux hivers kahnisme
un vaccin efficace
des politiques aux abonnés absents des
médias peut concerner la grippe de hong
kong a tué des milliers de français dans
l'indifférence générale
[Musique]
cinquante ans plus tard le couronne à
virus est une obsession nationale
toute l'action du gouvernement et du
parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie
mobilisation des services de santé comme
jamais bel
arrêt forcé d'industrie entière
hier en france
1723 personnes sont passées aux urgences
pour une suspicion d'infection koffi 19
notre pays tout entier avec tu au rythme
d'un macabre décompte quotidien du
directeur général de la santé en direct
à la télévision
et au plus haut sommet de l'état c'est
le ton des conférences de presse
permanente
vous voyez sur la carte que les tensions
sanitaires restent importantes dans la
région ile-de-france le pouvoir
politique a contraint les français de
2020 à s'enfermer durant huit semaines
il a mille tout un pays en apnée je l'en
totalement son économie
des décisions radicales et inédite qui
prouve combien notre société a changé en
cinquante ans maintenant ville aucun
gouvernement ne peut au monde ne peut
faire passer l'économie cas dans le
sanitaire ou ne pas faire passer le
sanitaire aventure tout le monde va
changer la sensibilité générale a changé
aujourd'hui il est sûr que le prix de la
vie humaine est beaucoup plus important
à nos yeux
sûrement qu'à cette époque là
parmi ces changements une vague venue
des états unis dans les années 80
les deux profs de gym les plus célèbres
de l'atelier pouvoir faire du sport à
plus de 12 millions de français chaque
dimanche matin
quinze ans après la grippe de hong kong
les français sont séduits par cette
tendance qui met en avant le bien-être
le sport et la nourriture saine plus
qu'un phénomène de mode le rapport au
corps est en train de changer
la santé devient une priorité qu'il soit
dit jean par rapport à eux-mêmes
ce privé de bien manger ou s obliger à
faire du sport ils vont être aussi
exigeants vis-à-vis de leurs dirigeants
de leur médecin
les progrès de la médecine vont
conforter les français dans l'idée qu'on
peut repousser la mort
mais c'est une épidémie des années 80
qui va placer l'état au centre de toutes
les attentions ni terre
pour moi la politisation de la santé est
arrivé avec l'épidémie du vih/sida
c'est là où les médias se sont emparés
du sujet c'est là où les politiques ont
été interpellés c'est là où
l'organisation du système de santé a été
mise en cause
est un scandale d'état fait passer les
politiques pour la première fois sur le
banc des accusés l' affaire du sang
contaminé fit plus d'un millier de morts
empoisonnés par des transfusions
sanguines les services de l'état sont en
cause les politiques sont obligés de
monter au créneau
après beaucoup de réflexion
nous avons décidé de rendre ce dépistage
obligatoire
généralisation qui interviendra
rapidement
représentera je dois le dire à
l'assemblée nationale un coût pour la
collectivité
d'environ 200 millions de francs par an
pour quatre millions de temps du sens
quand j'ai entendu fabule expliqué et
dire qu'à partir de maintenant c'était
une épidémie je me suis dit je n'étais
pas la seule ue c'est pourquoi c'est un
premier mini semaine se mêle un truc
comme ça oui c'est vrai qu'on s'est dit
les ceux qui nous gouvernent ont un
devoir de santé vis-à-vis nous voilà
en
1999 l'ancien premier ministre laurent
fabius et les anciens ministres de la
santé georgina dufoix et edmond hervé
comparaissent devant la cour de justice
de la république pour homicide
involontaire
laurent fabius et georgina dufoix sont
relaxés edmond hervé est condamné
ouah hervé c'est sûr est coupable de ma
contamination mais il n'était pas le
seul
premier du genre le procès n'est que le
début d'une longue liste du scandale des
hormones de croissance à celle de
l'amiante les politiques et l'état ont
dû rendre des comptes devant la justice
trente ans après la crise de hong kong
même un thermomètre qui s'affolent peut
déstabiliser un gouvernement en août
2003 la canicule s'abat sur la france la
chaleur finira par tuer 15000 personnes
et une image va choquer les français
c'est celle de jean françois mattei
ministre de la santé oms paulo depuis sa
maison de vacances dans le var qui tente
de se justifier au ministère de la santé
avait vous sous-estimez les conséquences
sanitaires de cette canicule notamment
pour les personnes âgées je ne pense pas
du tout qu'il y ait une sous-estimation
pour sous-estimer il faut être avertis
or cette canicule n'était pas prévisible
aucune plainte envers lui n'a abouti
mais vingt ans plus tard l'ancien
ministre garde un goût amer de cet
épisode
vous me demandez pourquoi
mais tout simplement parce que c'est une
règle qui est raconté dans la bible il
faut un bouc émissaire comme s'il vous
arrive quelque chose de grave il doit y
avoir un responsable
et d'ailleurs c'est dans la fable de la
fontaine aussi des animaux malades de la
peste il fallait qu'ils trouvent ce pelé
ce galeux d'où venait tout le mal
dans la crise du coc vide 80 plaintes
ont déjà été déposées contre le ministre
de la santé et ses collègues du
gouvernement
contre des hauts fonctionnaires aussi à
l'origine de ces plaintes des médecins
qui reproche le manque de masques ou des
citoyens qui déplore l'organisation du
premier tour des élections municipales
et même des policiers atteints du virus
aujourd'hui prendre des responsabilités
c'est prendre des risques d'être devant
la justice il est vrai que la
judiciarisation
va probablement
conduire à une raréfaction de ceux qui
veulent d'assumer des postes de
responsabilité le monde c'est tellement
judiciariser que des multinationales qui
s'estiment lésés par le confinement
veulent attaquer des états qui ont
imposé la mesure
les politiques préservé durant des
décennies
sont désormais au coeur de la cible